aubry wanted to see if there is a
connection between the time a given exam
takes place and the average score of
this exam she collected data about exams
from the previous year
plot the data in a scatter plot and
let's see they give us a couple of rows
here this is the class then they give us
the period of the day that the class
happened and then they give us the
average score on an exam and
one could you know there we have to be a
little careful with the study maybe
there's some correlation depending on
what subject is taught during what
period but let's just use her data at
least just based on her data see if she
will definitely do what they're asking
us plot a scatter plot and then see if
there is any connection
so let's see on the vertical on on the
horizontal axis we have period and on
this investigation this this exploration
she's doing she's trying to see well
does does the period of the day somehow
drive average score so that's why period
is on the horizontal axis and the thing
that's being the thing that's driving is
on the horizontal the thing that's being
driven is on the vertical so let's plot
each of these points period 1 average
score 93 period 1 average score
93 right over there period 6 87
period 6
80 oh that's not the right place and
then we can move it if we want 87 right
over there period 270 2
period 270
period 4 62
4 and 62 right over there
period 4 and 86 period 4 and again an 86
that's right over there
period 173 period 1
period 3 average score of 73 as well
period 3
period 1 80 average core of 80. so
period one average core of 80. and then
period three average score of 96. period
three
average score of 96. so there we go and
it doesn't really seem like there's any
obvious any obvious any obvious trend
over here so let's make sure that we got
this
right
and we did